apparently  apparently king g8 was completely drawn  but king h8 now magnus will play king g6  and  hang on what what is the big difference  i have no idea i mean hang on that is is  the queen g7 check and stamina the idea  if it's king rg8 all right oh my god  show it you we have to show it to the  viewers yes i mean let me get this yeah  that's he's so cute yeah if the king  goes back to g8 then after king g6 we  have this this kind of stamina idea  queen g7 takes and then b1 queen and if  queen f5 we may play queen e4 or what  yeah we just yeah we we can continue  this is so cute  wow  yeah and then magnus goes king g6 yeah  that's exactly the reason why we're  saying like okay just calculate the  force line till the end just don't give  all this practical